économie environnement énergie au social
et
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant
bonjour je m'appelle dimitri je suis
éco-délégués mes camarades et moi sommes
de la saq ing et nous allons vous
présenter un éco gestes pour limiter le
gaspillage de papier
ses feuilles blanches qu'on peut encore
servir regarde il est encore les deux
faces blanche tu peux aider cela sans
placer pour nico
notre collège dans chaque classe que
notre éco geste a été de mettre de
placer des poubelles une pour le papier
à recycler et une pour le brûlant
je
ne la jette pas dans la poubelle crise
mais là plus tôt dans la campagne du
parti en russie
c'est fait chèrement 2011 tu peux y
mettre dans la poubelle à bron
soyons tous écolos pour que le monde
soit plus beau maintenant c'est à vous
de jouer
je peux économiser jusqu'à 140 euros sur
mes factures edf
comment j'ai tant les lumières en
quittant la pièce ainsi que l'ordinateur
la radio la chaîne et le téléviseur
quand ceux ci ne sont pas utilisés
jaillir les pièces en faisant des
courants d'air le matin et on edge ferme
les volets du tire les rideaux alors
vous voyez préserver l'environnement
c'est augmenter votre pouvoir d'achat le
conseil général agit brute développement
durable et vous
économie environnement énergie au social
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant